this is a a beet sandwich how is this
different and I was just gonna be size
of these a beefsteak my sexy best to a
restaurant okay and you have to build
this okay so this is instead of a
hamburger you make a beet burgers that
right so this is a bead that I boil for
over 30 minutes
mm-hmm and outside looks ugly but as you
peel as you take out the skin inside you
have a sexy beautiful red I mean look
more excited oh man too much pressure on
me I was just looking at a beet sorry
so you're right I'm ready to go man okay
here have another show father so what do
you do you put some Mayo Mayo Mayo you
say Meyer I say okay and then we go and
we put the beet you put a beat right on
top of that right on top okay and more
Mayo yeah
that's a lot of Mayo what do you need
the beet I'm happy with the Mayo and the
bread
I said sexy vegetables man you're right
they're right that was a yolk and then
you put the leaf of these letters and
you put some onion right and then you
put these baby greens alfalfa sprouts
and then you top it oh my friend for you
only for you only for me can any tonight
let's see you beat sandwich oh yeah
and that was the beet juice situating
with the beat oh yeah I always had me
juice because before I boil them I love
to have the videos I mean you need to
think like when you don't know how to
cook and you never use a knife before
if you become working with beets it's
okay because you cut yourself nobody's
gonna notice I mean this is a good alibi
not thinking about killing somebody make
a beet
no that's a terrible idea I mean I was
defeated I did I didn't know that I was
bleeding to death because so this is the
beet juice right here yeah drink it
that's what I'm talking about why is
everyone running away I'm just making a
beet sandwich you know you're a strange
man
yeah always entertaining and I love
having you on the show
beefsteak currently has two locations I
love anyone tuning in right now hi I'm
dying
beefsteak surely that's two locations in
Washington DC with two more what I don't
need what you're doing with two more
opening in DC you're holding that like a
baby with two more opening in DC in
Philadelphia this year chef Jose Andres
we're back
[Applause]